You were discussing this scan duction, which I'm sorry, that's the term now. I think it is. I've told my boss and a couple of people, I said, you know, Zach told me definitely not to use it, but it's just, and you can think of it as like, you know, a map reduce would be a map duction, a scan duction. There's like a bunch of like insert duction. It's, I don't know. I think Zach is onto something. And before we move on to the scan duction. Connor, I want a divorce.
你刚才在讨论那个 scan duction，抱歉，现在这个词是这么叫的。我觉得是的。我跟我的老板还有好几个人都说过，我说，你知道，扎克明确告诉我绝对不要用这个词，但它就是，你可以把它想象成，你知道，map reduce 就像是一个 map duction，一个 scan duction。还有一堆诸如 insert duction 之类的词。这，我不知道。我觉得扎克确实说到了点子上。在咱们接着聊 scan duction 之前，康纳，我想离婚。
Why? First of all. What? We're not married. You can't divorce me. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 127 recorded on April 5th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we finish our three-part conversation with Tristan Brindle. We talk about ChatGPT, his library flux, and more.
为什么？首先。什么？我们又没结婚。你不能跟我离婚。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 127 期，录制于 2023 年 4 月 5 日。我是康纳，今天和我一起主持的是我的搭档布莱斯，我们将完成与特里斯坦·布林德尔（Tristan Brindle）的三部分对话。我们聊了 ChatGPT、他的 flux 库等等。
So while we're here, because Emery just tweeted about this, this is CY. CY? I got tired of trying to improve my compiler's diagnostics. So you've got chat GPT to turn C++ error messages into English. Correct. That is correct. That is amazing. That is amazing.
所以既然我们在这儿，因为埃梅里刚好发了一条关于这个的推文，这就是 CY。CY？我厌倦了试图改进我的编译器的诊断信息。所以你让 chat GPT 把 C++ 的错误信息变成英文。没错。完全正确。这太棒了。这太棒了。
It's really, really good. Of course, this is by Emery Berger, the keynote speaker extraordinaire. Oh, sorry. I thought this was yours, Bryce. Oh. Like someone just, that's it. Like a new startup, you will make millions.
它真的非常非常棒。当然，这是由埃梅里·伯杰（Emery Berger）这位杰出的主题演讲嘉宾带来的。哦，抱歉。我还以为这是你的呢，布莱斯。哦。就像某个人，就这样。就像一个新创业公司，你会赚大钱的。
I feel like i've literally seen that tweet four times about like someone should just do a startup of like parsing c++ template emory created this other thing chat chat debug so like a basically it's a plugin for GDB that does the same thing. And then I started chatting with him about like, okay, well, I'd like that for compiler error messages. And we came up with the CY thing. But both of these are, I think, super brilliant. And one of the reasons is that you look at all these large language models and you look at what people are trying to do with them in terms of developer tools. And a lot of it is code synthesis, like having it help you write code, et cetera. And that's cool, but that's like an open-ended question, right?
我觉得我真的已经看过好四次那类推文了，大意是说应该有人开个创业公司专门解析 C++ 模板，埃梅里创建了另一个东西叫 chat chat debug，基本上它是 GDB 的一个插件，能实现同样的功能。然后我开始跟他聊天，探讨比如，好吧，我希望编译器错误信息也能这样。于是我们想出了 CY 这个东西。但这两个项目，我认为都超级棒。原因之一在于，你看看所有这些大语言模型，再看看人们试图在开发工具方面用它们做什么。很大一部分是代码合成，比如让它帮你写代码等等。这很酷，但那是一个开放式问题，对吧？
And when there's an open-ended question, I think there's multiple possible correct answers. And that also means that there's more room for it to do something that's wrong. And also, I think that you end up with a lot more cases where it maybe hallucinates or comes up with something that's nonsense. And also, there's been a lot of concern about the IP around code generated with an AI assistant. But this space is very different because this is root cause analysis. In both the debugging case and the compiler error case, what you're doing is you're saying,
当存在开放式问题时，我认为会有多个可能的正确答案。这也意味着它出错的空间更大。并且，我认为你会遇到更多这样的情况：它可能会产生幻觉，或者搞出一些胡说八道的东西。而且，人们对由 AI 助手生成的代码所涉及的知识产权问题也有很多担忧。但这个领域非常不同，因为这是根本原因分析。无论是调试的情况还是编译器报错的情况，你实际上是在说，
hey, I have this, you know, this thing happened. Here's the data. Summarize for me what the root cause was. And that is something that the current technology for large language models is very, very good at. And it's like a concrete problem. It's not an open-ended question. It's like, here's information, summarize it, and explain it to me. And that is something where things like Chet GPT really excels. So I think that we're going to see a lot of development in the space of AI-assisted software engineering tools. But I think that things like this are going to be the ones that are going to have the highest impact the quickest.
嘿，我有这个，你知道，发生了这个事。数据在这里。帮我总结一下根本原因是什么。而这正是大语言模型目前的 tehnology 非常非常擅长的事情。这是一个具体的问题。它不是一个开放式问题。它就像是，这里有信息，总结一下并向我解释。这正是像 ChatGPT 这样的工具真正大显身手的地方。所以我觉得我们会在 AI 辅助软件工程工具领域看到大量的发展。但我认为像这样的工具会是最快产生最大影响的工具。
Like I'm already like using this. I was using the CY thing to write the CY thing because I don't like know Python well enough. And I kept getting these Python errors when I was trying to change something. And then I was like, all right, I'm just going to ask it to, you know, to help me. And there was another thing that occurred, you know, one part of this little tool that we have to do is you have to figure out what you're
就像我已经开始在用这个了。我在写 CY 这个工具时就用到了 CY，因为我对 Python 还不算够熟。当我尝试修改某些东西时，一直遇到这些 Python 错误。然后我想，好吧，我这就去请求它（你知道的）来帮帮我。还有一件事发生了，你知道，我们必须做的这个小工具的一部分是，你得弄清楚你将要
going to send to the large language model. And You can't send all the source code because it has a limited context size. And so what you do in both the case of the debugger or in the case of the compiler diagnostic is you sort of, you have a, in both cases, you sort of have a backtrace. You know, with a debugger, it's, you know, stack frames, but with the compiler diagnostics, you also sort of get this backtrace style where it tells you in this place, I had this error, and then that was caused by this place and this place and this place. So what you go through, what you do is you go through that, you extract all the source locations, and then you go and you open up those files, you read in those, you know, some of the code around those source locations, and you send
发送给大语言模型的是什么。你不能把所有的源代码都发过去，因为它有上下文大小的限制。所以在调试器的情况下或编译器诊断的情况下，你做的是，你某种程度上会有一个回溯信息。你知道，对于调试器来说，它是栈帧，但对于编译器诊断来说，你也会得到这种回溯风格的东西，它会告诉你在这个地方我遇到了这个错误，然后那个错误是由这个地方、这个地方以及这个地方引起的。所以你遍历的过程是，你遍历那个回溯，提取出所有的源代码位置，然后你去打开那些文件，去读入那些（你知道的）源码位置周围的一些代码，并把它们发送
it to the large language model so that it can figure it out. What I'd like to eventually be able to do is to use the Clang API to, instead of extracting just random lines from the file, be like, okay, I want the definition of this function and this function and this function and send that around. But one of the things that occurred to me is we're still, we know, we were writing, we're writing some, some code to parse the compiler diagnostics and extract the source locations. And I just was thinking about it this morning because now we have to do it from all to make it work for multiple languages.
给大语言模型，这样它就能弄清楚情况了。我最终想做的是使用 Clang API，而不是从文件中提取随机行，而是说，好吧，我想要这个函数、这个函数和这个函数的定义，然后把这些发过去。但让我想到的一件事是，我们还在，你知道的，我们在编写一些代码来解析编译器诊断并提取源码位置。我今天早上还在想这个，因为现在我们必须处理所有这些，以便让它适用于多种语言。
I just originally wrote something that worked for C++ and then Emory wrote something, changed it to work for Rust diagnostics. And then I realized like, this doesn't work for all of the ways, for all the C++ compilers. Some of them output the source locations in different ways. And then like Python's a whole different story. And then I was like, why am I writing code to parse this stuff? Like what I should be doing is I should just be asking the large language model, hey, here's the full diagnostic. Give me back a list of all of the source locations that are in this diagnostic. And then I'll open up those source locations and then I'll send you the pieces of the source code that you need. And I mean, another idea is just you show it
我最初只是写了一个适用于 C++ 的东西，然后埃梅里写了些东西，把它改成了适用于 Rust 诊断的。然后我意识到，这并不适用于所有方式、所有的 C++ 编译器。其中一些编译器输出源码位置的方式各不相同。然后像 Python 又完全是另一回事了。接着我在想，为什么我要写代码来解析这些东西？我应该做的是直接去问大语言模型，嘿，完整的诊断信息在这里。把这个诊断信息中包含的所有源码位置列表返回给我。然后我去打开那些源码位置，接着把你需要的那部分源代码发给你。我的意思是，另一个想法是你就把它展示给它，
the diagnostic and you ask it, hey, tell me what parts of this source code you need to see to help explain to me what the problem is um and you you end up with like this feedback loop here um and yeah i uh i have drunk the kool-aid on this um yeah one mention of chat gpt and then bryce is off he's like oh i've been talking about this right now. 15 minutes later. Itching all day to talk about this with you, Connor. That does seem really cool. Yeah, I haven't seen the tweet. Yeah, I think that this is going to be a big deal.
把诊断信息展示给它，然后问它，嘿，告诉我你需要看到这段源代码的哪些部分，以便向我解释问题所在。然后你会在这里形成这样一个反馈循环。然后，是的，我，我已经彻底接受了这一套（被洗脑了）。是的，只要一提 ChatGPT，布莱斯就来劲了，他就开始，哦，我一直在聊这个。15 minutes later. 一整天都心痒痒想跟你聊这个，康纳。那听起来确实超酷。对，我还没看过那条推文。对，我觉得这会是一件大事。
Like a year ago when GitHub github co-pilot first came out i was like skeptical because like i i am very i am not the target audience for uh uh software engineering tools because like i am very old-fashioned and curmudgeon-y like are you vim in a terminal i use vi on a terminal um it's like i i don't know what an ide is i have no interest in one i don't want graphical tools i barely want like a build system i'm happy to just like write bash scripts i want it as simple as possible um i i'm not like even make is too much i'm not the target audience for this but um i i think that this is so i'm so blown away by this that i think that it's um it's compelling enough to make somebody like me want to change the way that i um develop software
就像一年前 GitHub Copilot 刚出来的时候，我还挺怀疑的，因为我，我非常，我不是软件工程工具的目标受众，因为我非常老派而且顽固。你是终端里的 vim 吗？我在终端里用 vi。就像我，我不知道 IDE 是什么，我对它一点兴趣也没有，我不想要图形化工具，我甚至几乎不需要构建系统，我乐意只写写 bash 脚本，我希望它越简单越好。我甚至，连 make 都嫌多，我不是这类工具的目标受众，但是，我对此大受震撼，以至于我认为它，它的吸引力足以让像我这样的人想要改变我开发软件的方式。
um and that to me makes it like if it's if it's that compelling to me then it's got to be a really big deal for all the people who are less stuck in their ways than me yeah yeah and genuinely like error messages in c++ are are a huge are a huge problem and they're you know a lot of people who use c++ daily or use c++ occasionally i should say you know they're not experts and the moment they're hit with like a 200 line error message i mean like imagine if imagine a future where like this is plugged into godbolt or like a future where there's like a github action where whenever your ci fails um the large language model explains to you the like in the github pr it's like hey i see that you're you know this build failed here's
对我而言，这使得它——如果它对我有这么大的吸引力，那么对于所有那些不像我这么因循守旧的人来说，这一定是一件非常了不起的大事。对，对。说真的，C++ 中的错误信息是一个巨大、巨大的问题，而且它们，你知道，很多每天使用 C++ 或偶尔使用 C++ 的人，我应该这么说，他们并不是专家，一旦他们遇到两百行的错误信息时——我的意思是，想象一下，想象这样一个未来：这个东西被接入了 Godbolt，或者想象这样一个未来，有一个 GitHub Action，每当你的 CI 失败时，大语言模型就会在 GitHub PR 中向你解释，比如，嘿，我看到你的，你知道的，这个构建在这里失败了，原因如下。
why the build failed or like better yet like hey i see that, it's like, hey, I see that you're, you know, this build failed. Here's why the build failed. Or like better yet, like, hey, I see that this build failed. Like here's why the build failed. And here's my suggestion. Here's my patch proposing a fix for it. And then the CI can run on the patch and then like it can just fix it automatically. That's it. I'm sold.
或者更好的是，比如，嘿，我看到，这就好比，嘿，我看到你的，你知道的，这个构建在这里失败了。构建失败的原因如下。或者更好的是，比如，嘿，我看到这个构建失败了。构建失败的原因是这样的。这是我的建议。这是我提议修复它的补丁。然后 CI 可以在这个补丁上运行，接着它就可以自动修复了。就是这样。我被说服了。
I'm in now. Yeah, there's so much stuff that like i have a website that is written in closure script that when you run it locally will like generate and the compiled down to javascript but like that's i shouldn't be pushing the compiled javascript like i should have a little github action that deploys using github pages that does that for me but like closure script is not popular enough that like i can easily go read something of like how to automatically do this via github actions i if i could just ask chat gpt just like yeah i just want a script that that like when i
我现在入坑了。对，有太多东西了，比如我有一个用 ClojureScript 写的网站，当你本地运行它时，会生成并编译成 JavaScript，但等等，我不应该把编译好的 JavaScript 推送到仓库里——我应该弄一个小的 GitHub Action，用 GitHub Pages 帮我部署。但 ClojureScript 又不够流行，以至于我不能随随便便去读到诸如“如何通过 GitHub Actions 自动完成这个”之类的教程。如果我能直接问 ChatGPT，就像是，嘿，我只想要一个脚本，当我
push my closure script changes you will go and download and and uh i'm pretty sure we're like maybe it doesn't do that right now but there's no way generation of like build system of like build systems was another is another low-hanging fruit that i've been thinking maybe maybe a big deal too oh and emory emory's got another really cool project that i just started checking out where it's called commentator and it automatically comments your code for it for you it's it's it's called Commentator, and it automatically comments your code for you. It's so clever. It's so clever.
推送我的 ClojureScript 更改时，你就会去下载并——而且我很确定我们可能会，也许它现在还做不到这一点，但构建系统生成之类的东西是另一个唾手可得的果实，我也一直在想这可能也是一件大事。哦，埃梅里，埃梅里有另一个非常酷的项目，我最近刚开始看，叫做 Commentator，它能自动帮你给代码写注释。它叫做 Commentator，能自动帮你给代码写注释。这太巧妙了。这太巧妙了。
He's a very clever man, I got to say. Yeah, we'll link a couple of Emery Burgers talks. But let's get back because I think we've only got, what, 15 minutes left before Bryce has to go? Yeah, before I turn into a pumpkin. We're going to share a screen, and we're going to share the tweets. So, I mean, we never – we never – Oh, yeah. We got completely sidetracked. This got mentioned two episodes ago now in the first episode that we had Tristan on because we're slicing and dicing this up.
不得不说，他是个非常聪明的人。对，我们会在Shownotes里放几个埃梅里·伯杰的演讲链接。但我们得言归正传，因为我觉得我们大概只剩下，什么，15分钟了，布莱斯就得走了？对，在我变成南瓜之前。我们要共享屏幕，然后我们要分享推文。所以，我的意思是，我们从来没有——我们从来没有——哦，对。我们彻底跑题了。这个话题在上上期节目中就被提到了，也就是我们邀请特里斯坦作为嘉宾的第一期节目，因为我们把访谈切成了好几段。
And I got – I brought this tweet up, but then we never actually read it. But we'll – maybe we'll come back to – and so this tweet, the tweet, we'll link it in the show notes. It says, given a sequence of N elements, should an exclusive scan yield N elements or N plus 1? And actually, let's just, we can read the tweet. I said it should be N plus 1 because that's what a prescan is. Anyways, the point being here, we were talking about scans. A prescan is definitely N plus 1. Scan is N. here we were talking about scans a pre-scan is definitely n plus one scan is n and actually yeah if you want to hear about post scan which goes from n to n minus one go listen to a raycast
然后我——我提到了这条推文，但我们当时其实并没有读它。不过我们可能会——也许我们会回过头来——所以这条推文，这条推文，我们会把它链接到节目shownotes中。它说，给定一个包含 N 个元素的序列，exclusive scan 应该产生 N 个元素还是 N 加 1 个？事实上，我们读一下也无妨，我们可以读一下这条推文。我说它应该是 N 加 1 个，因为这才是 prescan。无论如何，重点在这里，我们当时在讨论 scan。prescan 绝对是 N 加 1。scan 是 N。这里我们在讨论 scan，prescan 绝对是 N 加 1，scan 是 N。事实上，是的，如果你想听关于 post scan 的内容，也就是从 N 变成 N 减 1 的那种，去听听 Raycast
episode uh the most recent one i think where in j they have a primitive called fold which has six different flavors three of which are actually scans they call it like a multiple forwards fold and that one does not take an initial value as an argument and also does not make the first element of the output sequence of your scan result it's not equal to the first value of your input sequence. It just adds the first two values and that therefore you end up with one element less than your initial sequence. Does that make sense? Yeah.
的一期节目，应该是最近的一期吧，他们在 J 语言里有一个名为 fold 的原语，它有六种不同的变体，其中有三种实际上就是 scan。他们管这叫多重正向 fold（multiple forwards fold），那个操作不把初始值作为参数，而且也不会把你的 scan 结果输出序列的第一个元素设为与输入序列的第一个元素相等。它只是把前两个值相加，因此你最终得到的元素会比初始序列少一个。这说得通吗？对。
Am I right in thinking that C++ standard inclusive scan does the same thing if you don't provide an initial value. No. And so actually, let's go look at this. The answer, I believe, is no. I take no responsibility for whatever broken thing. But what's interesting is that this literally came up the other day in Jake Hempstead's fellow InVIDIA, and we have our CCCL meetings on Mondays. And I said that inclusive scan doesn't take an initial value, which I was wrong about. So exclusive scan is our pre-scan,
我没记错的话，如果不提供初始值，C++ 标准的 inclusive scan 也是这么做的吗？不是。事实上，让我们来看看这个。我相信答案是否定的。无论出现什么崩溃的代码，我概不负责。但有趣的是，这恰好是前几天在杰克·汉普斯特德（Jake Hempstead，NVIDIA 的同事）那里提出的，我们每周一开 CCCL 会。当时我说 inclusive scan 不需要初始值，而我记错了。所以 exclusive scan 是我们的 prescan，
but it's actually a broken pre-scan because we've talked about this on the podcast before. It is a pre-scan that only gives you back N elements when it should give you back N plus one, because it just decides to not give you back the last one arguably the most important value in the output sequence which at one point we've also talked about this bryce used to disagree now he agrees
但它实际上是一个残缺的 prescan，因为我们在播客里以前讨论过这个。它是一个只能返回 N 个本该返回 N 加 1 个元素的 prescan，因为它武断地决定不返回最后一个元素——可以说它是输出序列中最重要的数据。我们曾经也讨论过这一点，布莱斯以前不同意，现在他同意了。
and i thought inclusive scan was uh the parallel equivalent of partial sum. But if you look at the first two overloads here, they take input iterators first and last and then an output iterator. But if you keep going down, at some point, there's a TNIT. Look at this. So I actually, so what is this? This is number five,
我以前以为 inclusive scan 是 partial sum 的并行等价物。但如果你看看这里的前两个重载，它们接受 first 和 last 输入迭代器，然后是一个输出迭代器。但如果你继续往下看，在某个地方，有一个 TNIT。看这个。所以实际上，那么这是什么？这是第 5 个重载，
and there's also a TNIT on 4.5. So let's look at what five does. Where does it describe these? Does it describe them? Doesn't even describe them by number. So let's see when it, let's actually just Google, or let's just search on the page. Computes the inclusive prefix sum operation using the binary op or std plus for overloads that use the default, using init as the initial value if provided, and writes the result to the range beginning at d first inclusive, which means that the ith input element is included in the ith sum. So because they don't mention anything about a differing number of output elements, my guess is that init is just automatically added to the first element.
在 4.5 处还有一个 TNIT。我们来看看第 5 个重载是做什么的。它在哪里描述了这些？它有描述吗？它甚至没有按编号描述它们。让我们看看它是什么时候，让我们直接 Google 一下，或者在页面上搜索。使用二元运算（binary op）或 std::plus 来计算 inclusive 前缀和操作，对于使用默认值的重载，如果提供了 init 则将其用作初始值，并将结果写入以 d_first_inclusive 开头的范围，这意味着第 i 个输入元素被包含在第 i 个和中。所以因为它们没有提到输出元素数量不同的情况，我猜 init 只是自动加到了第一个元素上。
So it's like partial sum, whereas if you're doing a partial plus scan, partial plus sum on 1, 1, 1, 1, 1 one you end up with one two three four five but in this if you're using inclusive scan and you specify a knit to be 10 then you're going to end up with 11 12 13 14 15 i think but i could be wrong about this um i think it's incredibly confusing that is is there another algorithm in c++ that has a overload that specifies basically an optional initial value i can't think of a single one i mean yeah i think this is the only one and that's the reason why that's the reason why it's last here but it's for exclusive scan, it's before the binary operation, which is in the parameter list order. That is, of course, fun.
所以它就像是 partial sum，如果你对 1, 1, 1, 1, 1 做 partial plus scan、partial plus sum，你最终会得到 1, 2, 3, 4, 5，但在这种情况下，如果你使用 inclusive scan 并指定 init 为 10，那么你最终会得到 11, 12, 13, 14, 15，我想是的，不过我也可能搞错。嗯，我觉得这极其令人困惑。C++ 中还有没有另一个算法拥有指定一个基本上是可选初始值的重载？我想不出哪怕一个。我是说，对，我觉得这是唯一的一个。这就是为什么，这就是为什么它在这里排在最后。但对于 exclusive scan 来说，它在二元操作之前，也就是参数列表的顺序里。这当然很有意思。
And at one point, it was not that way. It was reversed. But we like to have them appear in order as if it was defaulted if it's not provided. Oh, look at that. I've been exposed. I went to Gobbolt and it's at Rust by default, not C++. I'm actually curious. So I have just tried this out with inclusive scan, and I can tell you that if you don't provide the initial value, you get N elements. And what if you provide the initial value, what happens?
曾经有一段时间，它不是这样的。顺序是反过来的。但我们希望它们按顺序出现，如果未提供的话，就好像它是默认的一样。哦，你看这个。我暴露了。我上了 Gobbolt，默认是 Rust 而不是 C++。其实我挺好奇的。我刚刚用 inclusive scan 试了一下，我可以告诉你，如果不提供初始值，你会得到 N 个元素。如果提供初始值会发生什么？
It just adds it to the first. Okay. Yeah. So it is, I was going to say, we shouldn't, we shouldn't be misinforming our, yeah, that is. No, no, that was, that was me. That was my mistake. Apologies. I was. Oh, no, no. I was saying, I was saying that about like, I just said, I think that's the way it works, but I had no eye clue. So I was saying i was saying that about like i just said i think that's the way it works but uh i had no eye clue so i was i was saying that like potentially i just misinformed people by guessing at what i thought it did when i realized i could go one of us could go code this in probably less than 30 seconds so yes i think that answers answers the question which then i mean that really is kind of upsetting. Because, yeah, like std reduce, technically, you don't need to specify an initial value.
它只是把它加到第一个元素上。好的。对。所以它是，我本想说，我们不应该，不应该误导我们的，对，就是这样。不，不，那是，那是我的错。抱歉。我当时。哦，不，不。我刚才说的是，我只是说，我觉得它是那样工作的，但我根本一无所知。所以我当时说，我当时说，可能我只是通过猜测它可能是怎么工作的来误导了大家，当我意识到其实我完全可以——我们当中随便一个人大概能在 30 秒内写出这段代码来测试。所以，是的，我想这就回答了这个问题，这其实真的让人有点沮丧。因为，是的，就像 std::reduce 一样，从技术上讲，你不需要指定初始值。
But that's just because, well, I guess maybe that is kind of similar. So std reduce, if you don't specify initial value, it's set to zero, which I guess is kind of the same behavior here. I don't know, though. I don't like it. Anyways, that was the – i want to get back to flux um that was the tweet oh right that uh initially set this up and we've answered it now a full two episodes later for those that were like they were going to talk about a tweet and we got 10 10 or 15 minutes left and this is the other tweet i actually have this linked let's bring up that
但那只是因为，好吧，也许这确实有点类似。所以 std::reduce，如果你不指定初始值，它会被设为零，我想这跟这里的行为差不多。不过我不知道。我不喜欢这样。不管怎样，那是——我想回到 flux 那里。这就是那条推特，哦对了，它最开始引发了这个话题，而我们现在在整整两期节目之后才回答了它，对于那些当时以为我们会讨论一条推特、而我们还剩 10 到 15 分钟的人来说——这就是另一条推特，我其实把链接放进去了。让我们把那个
github repo so there's a github GitHub repo I've mentioned a couple times called Top 10, which currently only has eight problems, but they are eight of my favorite problems that I've ever come across. And I've talked about them in talks, in these ADSP episodes, and you can see down here at the bottom, three consecutive odds. I've linked to your sort of Twitter thread, thread tristan on your various solutions using flux oh where'd it go which one is it there it is because i just think it's fantastic one it highlights how awesome flux is so i'm not sure we said we'll never do this where we show code and then the uh the the listener doesn't get to see but uh because i think this is a great way of highlighting like one how awesome flux is
GitHub 仓库调出来。所以有一个 GitHub 仓库，我提过好几次，叫 Top 10，目前只有 8 个问题，但它们是我遇到过的最喜欢的 8 个问题。我在演讲中、在这些 ADSP 节目中都聊过它们。你可以在底部看到，三个连续的奇数（three consecutive odds）。我链接到了你的推特讨论串，特里斯坦，关于你使用 flux 的各种解决方案。哦，去哪了？到底是哪一个？哦，找到了，因为我觉得这太棒了。一方面，它突显了 flux 是多么厉害。所以我不确定我们说过——我们绝不会这样做，就是我们展示代码，然后听众却看不到——但是，因为我觉得这是一个绝佳的方式来突出，一方面 flux 有多厉害，
but just to like my sort of passion for algorithmic thinking because it highlights sort of all the different ways. So I'm not sure if we want to spend the whole 10 minutes popping through these or you only want to explain a couple of these. Also to three consecutive odds if you happen to also this being your first episode it's given a sequence of integers return true if there's at least three consecutive odd numbers in a row otherwise false yeah i'm not sure what how you want to do this tristan or if you want to walk people at a high level through the flavors or only look at a couple of them because it's uh this is like idyllic code in my in my mind oh well thank you very much um yeah so this was uh i so every friday i get a new episode of adsp uh you know my phone tells me there's a new episode out and then um i i go and i i take a walk
另一方面也展现了我对算法思维的热情，因为它突出了各种不同的解法。所以我不太确定我们是想花整整 10 分钟逐个过一遍这些解法，还是你只想解释其中的几个。顺便说一句，关于“三个连续奇数”这个问题，如果你恰好也是第一次收听这档节目，它的要求是：给定一个整数序列，如果里面至少有三个连续的奇数就连在一起，则返回 true，否则返回 false。对，特里斯坦，我不确定你想怎么处理这个，或者你是想从高层级向大家介绍这些不同的变体，还是只看其中的几个，因为这在我的脑海里简直是——这就像是理想中的代码。
and i listen to the podcast and this one this particular episode uh was it the first one where you were talking to zach um and? And I just thought this was a really, really interesting problem. And I went home and I was like, how would I do this? You know, I've got my own library for doing this. How would I do it in Flux? And so I've got a few tweets that we will link to, I guess, in the show notes. And so the first one is just um it's not using any sort of library it's just using uh you know a for loop and smith statements kind of naive way of doing it without any library trickery and that's kind of okay yeah i'll say in the tweet like i'm sure this will this would be some people's preference and i'm sure connor you mustn't you get comments on your youtube
哦，非常感谢。嗯，所以这是——我，所以每周五我都会收到一期新的 ADSP 节目，你知道，我的手机提醒我新节目上线了，然后，嗯，我就会出去散步，
videos going like why don't you just do it the c way with a for loop and this is how you would do it uh that way but you know you know i like doing this this uh i like using algorithms and things um so i went on and i did it uh a couple of other ways i use this um this for each while algorithm that we were talking about. It doesn't make, it doesn't do an awful lot in this particular example. I would say it doesn't actually improve the readability at all compared to the imperative code
听播客。这一期，这一期节目特别——是和扎克聊的那期吗？我觉得这是一个非常非常有趣的问题。我回家后就在想，我会怎么做？你知道，我也有自己的库来做这件事。我在 Flux 中会怎么做？所以我有几条推特，我想我们会在Shownotes里放上它们的链接。第一条只是，它没有使用任何库，只是用了一个简单的 for 循环和 if 语句，这是一种比较朴素的做法，没有任何库的奇技淫巧，这也挺好的。对，我在推特上也说过，我确信这会是某些人的首选，而且康纳，你肯定也在你的 YouTube 视频下收到过这样的评论，说：“为什么不用 C 风格的 for 循环来做呢？”如果你用那种方式，代码就会是这样的。但你知道，你知道我喜欢这样做，我喜欢使用算法之类的方法。
that we were using before. In some cases, the forEachWhile might be, as we were talking about with internal iteration, it might be able to do things more efficiently than a plain old for loop. But in this particular case, it doesn't make any difference. And the generated code is the same either way. Interesting.
所以我继续用其他几种方式实现了它。我用了我们刚才讨论过的这个 forEachWhile 算法。在这个具体的例子中，它并没有发挥太大的作用。我得说，和我们之前使用的命令式代码相比，它并没有真正提高代码的可读性。在某些情况下，就像我们讨论内部迭代时所说的那样，forEachWhile 可能比纯粹的旧式 for 循环更高效。但在这种特定情况下，它没有任何区别。无论用哪种方式，生成的代码都是一样的。
So this, the Lambda that your forEachWhile takes actually, it does have a return value. Yeah. Which is different than... I may have to steal this idea. This is very clever. Be my guest. Be my guest. It basically gives you the...
有趣的是。那么，你的 forEachWhile 接收的 lambda 实际上确实有一个返回值。是的。这与……不同……我可能得偷师这个主意。这太巧妙了。请便，请便。它基本上赋予了你……
Well, that's what the comment says exactly. But it gives you the ability to short circuit. Exactly. Yeah. That's precisely the point of it yeah very interesting okay well we'll link all this stuff so that folks that want to take a look um can we'll move on to the next this is it's hard it's hard for me which one is more beautiful this solution or the next one i i don't know. But this code is, it's just makes me so happy. Makes me so happy. So the next one was actually my, when I was listening to the episode, this was, I was walking along and I was like, how do I do it in my head? And this was the way I thought of doing it. So you take your input vector of integers
嗯，注释里就是这么写的。但它赋予了你短路的能力。没错。对。这正是它的精髓所在。非常有趣。好吧，我们会把所有这些东西都链接起来，以便想要看的听众能够查看。我们将继续下一个。这对我来说很难抉择，究竟哪个更美观，是这个解决方案还是下一个？我不知道。但这段代码，真的让我太开心了。让我太开心了。所以下一个实际上是——当我听节目时，我一边散步一边在想，我该怎么在脑子里实现它？这就是我想到的方法。所以你拿到你的整数输入 vector，
and then you map it to a sequence of bools, depending on whether each element is true or false. And then you step through that Boolean sequence three elements at a time, and you look at the three bools and you say, are these all true? And if they are, then you terminate and you say, yes, they are. Otherwise, you keep going until either they're all true or you reach the end of the array, in which case they're not. So if you look at the tweet, you have to do this in a
然后把它映射到一个布尔值序列，取决于每个元素是真还是假。然后你以每次三个元素的速度遍历那个布尔序列，观察这三个布尔值，然后问：这些全都是真的吗？如果是的话，你就终止并说，是的，它们全是真的。否则，你就继续下去，直到要么它们全是真的，要么你到达了数组末尾，那种情况下就不是。所以如果你看那条推特，你必须以一种
slightly strange way. You have to provide this ID predicate which just like passes through the identity function you had yeah but yeah I this was my sort of instinctive instinct is maybe my intuitive algorithm intuition my intuitive way that I thought to do this but actually as a result of the episode, you were discussing this scan-duction, which I'm sorry, that's the term now. I think it is. I've told my boss and a couple people. I said, you know, Zach told me definitely not to use it. But it's just – and you can think of it as like, you know, a map reduce would be a map-duction, a scan-duction. There's like a bunch of like insert-duction.
稍微有些奇怪的方式来做。你必须提供这个 ID 谓词，它只是透传了你有的恒等函数。对，不过是的，这是我的一种直觉反应，也许是我的直觉算法、我想出这个方法的直觉方式。但事实上，作为那期节目的延续，你当时在讨论那个 scan duction，抱歉，现在这个词是这么叫的。我觉得是的。我跟我的老板还有好几个人都说过，我说，你知道，扎克明确告诉我绝对不要用这个词，但它就是——你可以把它想象成，你知道，map reduce 就像是一个 map duction，一个 scan duction。还有一堆诸如 insert duction 之类的词。
It's – I don't know. I think Zach is on to something. And before we move on to the scanduction. Connor, I want a divorce. Why? First of all, what? We about this is that uh instead of adjacent transform which is what we're getting in c++ 23 flux calls this adjacent map which is in my mind the actual true name of this algorithm which is actually i'm not sure if you are aware of this but it's uh that is the name of the algorithm in haskell uh it's in a library but adjacent map is like is what it should be called but we have to call it in C++ adjacent transform because we are the only language on the planet, that I know of at least, that calls their maps transforms. Very unfortunate.
这——我不知道。我觉得扎克确实说到了点子上。在咱们接着聊 scan duction 之前。康纳，我想离婚。为什么？首先。什么？关于这个，不同于 C++23 中的 adjacent transform，Flux 把它叫做 adjacent map，在我看来这才是这个算法真正的名字。其实我不知道你知不知道，这正是 Haskell 中这个算法的名字。它在一个库里，但 adjacent map 才是它本该被叫的名字。不过我们在 C++ 中不得不把它叫作 adjacent transform，因为据我所知，我们是地球上唯一一个把 map 叫做 transform 的语言。非常不幸。
Map is a data structure, so we have to call it transform. But Flux, I call the transform operation map. And there is a map right above it that is also the correct name for what we have to call transform. But also you have these built-in predicates and sort of convenience functions. So you mentioned ID, which is the identity function. But you also have like odd, which is not like a necessary thing. But it's just like it's a very nice convenience for when you need to do things like that, which is awesome. Yeah.
Map 是一种数据结构，所以我们必须叫它 transform。但在 Flux 中，我把 transform 操作叫做 map。在它正上方还有一个叫做 map 的东西，那也是我们不得不叫 transform 的那个东西的正确名称。但你也有这些内置的谓词和便利函数。所以你提到了 ID，也就是恒等函数。但你也有像 odd 这样的东西，这倒不是什么必需的东西。但它确实非常方便，当你需要做类似的事情时，这就很棒。对。
So there are only about half a dozen of these little predicates, but it's mostly just because I was writing tests and I just kept on using these little predicates like is positive, is even, is odd, is zero. And I was just like, if I find these useful, someone else is going to find them useful. So as I say, I think there are only six or eight or something, not very many, but they're there.
所以这类的微型谓词只有大半打左右，但主要还是因为我在写测试时，一直在反复使用这些小谓词，比如 is_positive、is_even、is_odd、is_zero。我就在想，如果我觉得这些有用，别人也会觉得有用。所以正如我所说，我想大概只有六到八个左右，不是很多，但它们就在那里。
And you can, they're actually, there's nothing really flux specific about it you can use them with the standard library algorithms and everything it's very very nice small touch like that language like closure and a lot of lisps actually they have like you know is positive or pos question mark like just these nice small things that like how hard is it to write you know greater than zero it's not hard at all but like it's also nicer to just read like is pause and like not have to wrap something in a Lambda, which especially in C++ can be unnecessarily verbose as we all know. But anyways, we'll, we'll move on to the scan induction solution, which is also very nice.
而且你可以——其实 Flux 对此没有什么特殊的限制，你可以把它们和标准库算法以及所有东西一起使用。诸如此类的小细节非常非常好。像 Clojure 这样的语言和许多 Lisp 实际上都有诸如 is_positive 或 pos? 这样的小东西，写出“大于零”到底有多难？一点也不难，但阅读起来像 is_pos 这样会更清爽，而不必把某些东西包在一个 lambda 里，正如我们所知，尤其在 C++ 中，那可能会变得不必要地冗长。不管怎样，我们继续讲 scan duction 的解法，它也非常棒。
Yes. So the, the, the solution with the, with the adjacent map is fine. It, you know, it works. It gives the right answer. It's pretty good. It has the downside that for kind of implementation reasons, it's calling the is odd transform multiple times. So the way the adjacent map works is that it sort of has like internally,
是的。所以，用 adjacent map 的那个解法挺好的。它能行，它能给出正确答案。它挺不错的。它的缺点是，由于某种实现原因，它会多次调用 is_odd transform。所以 adjacent map 的工作方式是，它在内部某种程度上拥有，
well, three cursors in flux, but you can think of it as three iterators. And every time you dereference them, it has to call the predicate on the underlying thing. So it's fine, but it calls the predicate more often than it really needs to. So the scan avoids that. And so what we do is we perform this scan, we begin at the beginning and we return the number of consecutive odd elements we've seen so far. So, let's say you have one, three, five,
嗯，在 Flux 中有三个游标，不过你可以把它想象成三个迭代器。每次你解引用它们时，它都必须对底层对象调用谓词。所以这没问题，但它调用谓词的频率比实际需要的要高。所以 scan 避免了这一点。因此我们做的是，我们执行这个 scan，从头开始，并返回到目前为止我们看到的连续奇数元素的数量。所以，假设你有 1、3、5，
then your scan is gonna be one and then two and then three, because that's the number of odd elements you've seen so far. And so we do this scan we transform our range of ints into well another range of ints which is how many odd elements we've seen the count of all elements so far and if we see an even element we reset the count to zero and then we go through and we have this uh Flux, it's called any, in the standard library, it's called any of. And we look to see, OK, are any of the values in this scan greater than or equal to three?
那么你的 scan 结果就会是 1，然后是 2，然后是 3，因为那是你到目前为止看到的奇数元素的数量。所以我们做这个 scan，把我们的 int 范围转换成——另一个 int 范围，也就是我们见过的奇数元素的数量，到目前为止所有元素的计数。如果我们看到一个偶数元素，就把计数重置为零。然后我们遍历它，并且我们有这个——在 Flux 中叫 any，在标准库中叫 any_of。我们来看看，好吧，这个 scan 中的任何一个值是否大于或等于 3？
And again, if you look at the tweet, and this is maybe not great audio only, but yeah, so we're using another one of these Fl predicates. It's greater than or equal to three. I wonder, so you have a map. Maybe I'll go and, is flux, flux isn't available on Gobble, is it? This is, this is pretty clever. It is. So if you go to, so it's github.com slash tc brindle slash flux that's the there's uh i should say there is almost no documentation for flux yet like this is literally that's cool because there's a large language model that can make the documentation for you yeah um i might have
再次强调，如果你看那条推特——光听音频可能不太好理解，但对，我们正在使用另一个这样的 Fl 谓词。它大于或等于 3。我在想，所以你有一个 map。也许我会去——Flux，Flux 在 Godbolt 上不可用，对吧？这，这相当巧妙。它是可用的。所以如果你去，它是 github.com/tcbrindle/flux，这就是——这里有——我应该说，Flux 目前几乎没有什么文档——这真的很酷，因为有一个大语言模型可以帮你写文档。对，我可能
to look at that it might save me a lot of time um but uh i've got a little bit of introductory info i one of the my goals over the next um you know few weeks when i've got time is to write like documentation about how flux works internally and stuff um but uh i do have a single header that has you know because uh it's a header only like heavily used lots of templates and And so there's a single header file that you can just hash include in Godbolt because it's amazing. I always forget that. Go and download it. So there is, I believe in the readme,
得看看那个，可能会给我省不少时间。不过我有了一点入门信息。我接下来的，你知道，未来几周当我有空时的目标之一，就是编写关于 Flux 内部工作原理等内容的文档。但我的确有一个单头文件，里面有（因为它是仅头文件的库，大量使用了模板），所以有一个单独的头文件，你可以在 Godbolt 中直接 #include，因为这太棒了。我总是忘这个。去把它下载下来。所以，我相信在 readme 中，
there is a link to Godbolt and you can click that and it will take you to somewhere where you can play it. So it's not one of the built-in libraries drop down in Compiler Explorer. Sorry. But you can just do the hash include thing, which is pretty cool.
有一个指向 Godbolt 的链接，你可以点击它，它会带你到一个可以试玩的地方。所以它不是编译器资源管理器（Compiler Explorer）下拉菜单中内置的库之一。抱歉。但你只需做 #include 操作就行了，这非常酷。
The reason I ask this is because I kind of want to go, there's a slightly alternate version of this where you map, you do the same initial map that you did in the previous solution, map odd, to turn it into a sequence of ones and zeros. And then you can either simplify your lambda here to be, if you call the first argument of your lambda a and the second b, it can be, is it a plus b in parentheses
我之所以问这个，是因为我有点想去——这里有一个稍微替代的版本，你进行映射，做你在上一个解法中做的初始 map，即 map odd，把它变成一个由 1 和 0 组成的序列。然后你可以把你的 lambda 简化为：如果你把 lambda 的第一个参数叫 a，第二个叫 b，它就可以是，括号里的 (a + b)
times b? So it's like the times b will reset your odd count to zero if it's zero. Otherwise, it'll do a plus B on your A. So it'll either be your current odd count plus one in parentheses times one, or it'll be your current odd count plus zero times zero, which will reset it. And that pattern actually, actually your plus applied first and then or your your plus applied first and then your multiplies you can spell in array languages with a dyadic fork which is like a combinatory logic thing so and i happen to have a small library called blackbird so like if we combined flux andbird, you could get probably actually one line shorter.
乘以 b 吗？所以类似乘以 b 会在它为零时将你的奇数计数重置为零。否则，它会对你的 a 执行 a 加 b。所以它要么是你的当前奇数加一（加括号）乘以一，要么是你的当前奇数加零乘以零，这会将其重置。这种模式实际上——其实你的加法先应用，然后或者你的加法先应用，然后你的乘法，你可以在数组语言中用双向叉积（dyadic fork）来表达，这是一种组合子逻辑的东西。所以碰巧我有一个名为 blackbird 的小库，如果我们把 Flux 和 blackbird 结合起来，你大概可以把代码缩短一行。
Because right now you have three lines for your scan. You'd have one line for your map and then one line for your scan. Because you wouldn't have to spell out a lambda. You could just pass plus and times and identity to your Phi 1 combinator. Anyways, losing the listener. But yeah, both of these solutions are so beautiful. And people have a lot of nice things and not nice things to say about C++. But this is like we're close to the utopic world that one would want to live in if you're me coding in C++.
因为现在你的 scan 需要三行。你只需要一行 map 和一行 scan。因为你不需要写出 lambda。你只需要把 plus、times 和 identity 传给你的 Phi 1 组合子。不管怎样，我可能快失去听众了。不过是的，这两个解法都太美妙了。人们对 C++ 有很多好听和不好听的评价，但这就像是——如果我们这些在 C++ 中编程的人想要生活在一个乌托邦世界里，我们已经离它很近了。
Hopefully, we didn't lose all the listeners. We got to stop doing this though. I mean, says the person who shared his screen to walk through some code. It's hard to talk through tweets when I'm not sure whether people can see them. We do have to wrap up because my mom is texting me that it's time for yoga. All right. Well, so we got less than two minutes left. I know, Tristan, so first of all, thanks for coming on.
希望我们没有失去所有的听众。不过我们得停止这样做了。我是说，这话是由一个为了过一遍代码而共享屏幕的人说的。当我无法确定人们是否能看到时，对着推特夸夸其谈确实很难。我们必须收尾了，因为我妈妈发短信来说瑜伽时间到了。好吧。所以我们剩下不到两分钟了。我知道，特里斯坦，首先，谢谢你能来。
This has been awesome. We're going to have you back to talk about Find It versus Accumulate and all the ChatGPT things. I guess I'll stop sharing my screen while we do this. Before we go, though, I know that you – I think last time we chatted at CPP North, I think, was probably the last time, like in person, not over Twitter. You were freelancing and doing training and stuff. Is that still what you're... Because anyways, if this is an opportunity to plug what you're doing
这太棒了。我们以后还会邀请你来聊 Find It 与 Accumulate，以及所有关于 ChatGPT 的事情。我想在我们做这个的时候我把屏幕共享关了吧。不过在我们离开之前，我知道你——我想上次我们在 CPP North 聊天时，大概是上一次线下面对面而不是通过推特交流。你当时在做自由职业和培训之类的。现在还是那样吗？因为无论如何，如果这是一个宣传你在做的事情、
slash if you're going to be at any conferences, giving talks, now's the time to do all that sort of. Okay, so I am going to be this year at C++ on C. Also just heard a couple of days ago, my talk was accepted for CPP North as well. So I'll be going back to Toronto. So that's awesome because I had a really good time there last year. So I'm actually going to be talking about Flux and iteration and sort of the basics of iteration, how we can do these more safely at both conferences.
或者宣传你是否会去任何会议做演讲的机会，现在就是做这些广告的时候了。好的，我今年会去 C++ on Sea。另外几天前刚听到消息，我的演讲也被 CPP North 接受了。所以我还要回多伦多。这太棒了，因为我去年在那儿度过了一段非常美好的时光。所以实际上我会在两个会议上都聊到 Flux、迭代，以及迭代的基础知识，即我们如何能更安全地进行这些操作。
You know, the windows overlapped and I submitted the same talk for both conferences and they happened to both accept it. So I guess depending on whether it's easier to go to Europe or easier to go to North America, you can, if you wish, hear me chatting about that. So, yeah, really looking forward to that. It's going to be great. And I'll get to, well, I get to see you, Connor, I. It's going to be great. And I'll get to see you, Connor, I assume you're going to CPP North. Yeah, I'll be at both CPP North and C++ on C. So yeah, we'll see each other a couple of times. There's another idea. GPT plugin for PowerPoint.
你知道的，这两个会议的投稿时间重叠了，我给两个会议提交了相同的演讲，结果两边都接受了。所以我想，取决于去欧洲还是去北美更方便，如果你愿意的话，可以去听我聊这个话题。所以，是的，我真的很期待。这会很棒的。而且我能——嗯，我能见到你，康纳，我——这会很棒的。而且我能见到你，康纳，我猜你会去CPP North吧。对，我两个都会去，CPP North和C++ on Sea。所以，是的，我们会见好几次面。还有一个想法，PowerPoint的GPT插件。
Microsoft, get on that. I want that. I mean, they basically bought the whole company at this point. That would genuinely be a fun lightning talk, right? So you just get ChatGPT to like generate you a script
微软，快搞一个这个。我想要这个。我的意思是，他们现在基本上把整家公司都买下来了。那真的会是一个有趣的闪电演讲，对吧？所以你只需要让ChatGPT为你生成一个稿子
and just stand there for five minutes and read out. Yeah, yeah. I may do that. Half of the stuff that it generates, like when it's like, give us a promo for this podcast. It's like better than what I could have written cpt cast did that um but you covered the talks
然后就在那儿站五分钟读出来。对，对。我可能会那么做。它生成的一半内容，比如当它说“为这个播客写一个宣传语”时，比我自己写的还要好。cpt cast就是这么做的，嗯……但你涵盖了演讲内容
um are you available for training in case folks want that or absolutely absolutely yep so um uh if you if you want training on c++ i'm most definitely available uh get in contact with me um we can guess, put my email somewhere if you're interested in that. Otherwise, I'm on Twitter, if that's still going by the time this episode airs. So it's at Tristan Brindle at Twitter. I haven't got around to setting up Mastodon yet, but I will do that at some point. Otherwise, yeah. Awesome. Yeah. We'll throw all the links in each of these episodes even though the plugs happen in this one uh in the show notes and yeah folks
嗯，如果大家需要的话，你提供培训吗？当然，当然，是的。所以，嗯……如果你想要C++方面的培训，我绝对是随时候命的。联系我吧，如果你感兴趣的话，我们可以把我的邮箱放在某个地方。另外我在Twitter上，如果到这期节目播出的时候它还没倒闭的话。我的Twitter账号是@Tristan Brindle。我还没来得及设置Mastodon，但我迟早会弄的。不管怎样，是的。太棒了。是的。我们会把这些链接放在每一期节目的shownotes里，尽管广告是在这一期里做的，大家
can find you on twitter it is concerning that there has been uh the what is it shibu inu doge coin yes like what like that does seem like to be like i'm not sure if that's the beginning of the end or we're like very close to the end and the beginning was a long time ago. But it's been there for a few days now. I'm still convinced that he's going to get bored with it at some point. He kind of disappeared for a while. And then I thought that was it. But then he came back guns a-blazin'. Well, he had that poll with, like, should I quit as CEO?
可以在Twitter上找到你。让人有点担心的是，居然出现了那个……是什么来着？柴犬币、狗狗币？是的。就像……这看起来似乎……我不太确定这究竟是末日的开始，还是我们已经非常接近末日了，而开始是很久以前的事。但它已经在那里挂了好几天了。我依然坚信他迟早会对那个感到厌倦。他之前消失了一段时间，我以为那就结束了。但后来他带着满腔怒火又回来了。哦，他当时还搞了个民意调查，问“我应该辞去CEO职务吗？”
And everyone was like, yes. And then he just ignored it he's a large man child eventually he'll find some other toy to play to play with everybody you can it makes me very happy that apparently he tried to be the uh chairman of the board or something like that of open ai at one point because he was a yeah i don't i don't know what he was he probably says he's a co-founder when he wasn't and blah blah blah, blah. But like he had some association. And then I don't know what's his Sam Altman and Susquehanna. They were basically like, no, bye. Yeah.
然后所有人选了“应该”。接着他就当没看见。他就是个长不大的大男孩，总有一天他会找到别的玩具去玩。大家……这让我非常高兴，据说他曾经一度想当OpenAI的董事会主席什么的，因为他是个……是的，我不知道他算什么，他可能自称是联合创始人，但其实并不是，等等等等。但他确实跟他们有些渊源。然后，我不知道，山姆·奥特曼和萨斯奎汉纳（Susquehanna）基本上就是说：“不，再见。”是的。
So the guys that are the people that are behind chat to BT and all this LLM stuff, it makes me very happy that they very much ahead of the curve recognized that they didn't want anything to do with, with Mr. Musk. Yeah. All right. I really got to go. to do with Mr. Musk. Yeah. All right. I really got to go.
所以，那些开发ChatGPT和所有这些大语言模型（LLM）幕后的人，这让我非常高兴，他们很有远见地认识到，他们不想和马斯克先生有任何瓜葛。是的。好了。我真的得走了。
Yeah, Bryce has got to go. Thanks for coming on, Tristan. Okay. Thank you very much for having me. It's been awesome. Cheers, guys. Be sure to check your show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the things that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a
好的，布莱斯得走了。谢谢你来参加，特里斯坦。好的。非常感谢邀请我。太棒了。干杯，伙计们。请务必查看你的播客应用中的shownotes，或者访问ADSPthepodcast.com，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何事物的链接，以及一个
GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts, or questions about today's episode. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下关于今天节目的评论、想法或问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。